oh god and this [ __ ] tour de france
lady did you watch that i was gonna
oh you're gonna say what sorry no i was
oh it got taken down
i didn't see the tour de france lady you
didn't see this video no
oh it's so good please find it
please find it people get it someone
i might get it i might get really upset
here what someone interfering with a
race yeah i know
as a now race car boy yeah don't you
dare interfere with the race exactly
exactly politically or
like a political race yeah oh i see it
yeah
no i mean like don't interfere with the
race of people
definitely don't interfere with people
racing yes exactly
absolutely not all right here we go wait
wait you gotta play the beginning
does it show it all right so here they
are oh they don't
show this slow-mo because they're trying
to probably protect her identity
oh you think that's why hell yeah dude
okay
go back oh look at her oh
dummy dummy look at this guy just get
run over oh dummy alert
okay is she on the run
no way really she's trying to leave the
country
oh my god i'm making all out of her and
sue her
and they're trying to find her right now
as as to basically be like do not
ever interfere with this race ever again
it took
multiple racers out of the race and they
were like the leading team too right
i'm not sure i mean they're wearing the
yellow jersey isn't that
dog can you imagine yeah they're wearing
the yeah can you imagine a fan in
formula one
just like leans over the barricade and
like a sign just
just hits their helmet at 200. and they
think about this fan leaning over and
they're just getting evaporated
max verstappen absolutely crushing it
into turn three
it's someone's mom just exploded
annihilating that grandma
oh you can't get on track when you do
that it's just not
smart look at this again cloud of
dust formula one knowing them they'd be
like re replay
boys yeah it's just blood replay it
again replay it again
let's see it again let's see it again
run it like 400 more times
and here she is just leaning over and
there she goes annihilated
yeah yeah yeah he really shut the door
on her didn't he
wow there she is not
and that [ __ ] oh we'll we'll take off
this just quick second congratulations
to lewis hamilton for home depot's
fastest lap of the day
that's an extra point for him now back
to the replay
there she is again absolutely
annihilated yeah you can just see the
way her bone
structure just rips apart i think it
would be more like nonchalant because
you know british people it's just
darkness is in them so they'd be like
there she is there and she's gone
i mean wow formula one like
they love and she's gone
they love breaking down like when cars
crash they love just replaying it and
the announcers go
yeah you can see there the tie rod
really gets in the way and just the way
it
jitters over the curve so i feel like
they just break it down yeah
yeah the speed of the car it's just
human body can't handle it and you can
see actually one of her teeth
right there yeah dust blood
you'll need to refer to that to find out
her identity
because there's nothing left they'll
have to yeah there's nothing left
i do believe a steward has found a molar
so that's good oh that's good that's
good
damn uh
do you want to promote it no that's fine
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no just look oh we haven't even
talked about the love island show yet we
gotta
we started you know a little a little
love island
well limited run we're always talking
about it but we're just gonna take it
out of this and we'll just make it its
own thing
so yeah yeah we always talk about love
island anyways whenever the show no no
we don't have to
play this it's fine i think they all saw
it honestly if you didn't see the promo
video on twitter
or youtube go watch that but also the
first episode is up right now
yeah on our youtube channel and also
just on
uh patreon ad free and uh on our normal
podcast feed on spotify or whatever
we're just going to label it like tmg
bonus or whatever
yeah love island bonus but uh dude we're
gonna be watching the show we're gonna
be playing the game
yeah so follow along with us if you like
the show
it's gonna be a fun we shot the first
episode it's [ __ ] hollywood it was a
great time so much fun
we were yolked as [ __ ] and we've got
jacked we put the trend on for it
wait scroll to the top we got this mean
comment dude look at this you fell off
plus l plus ratio
plus yb did love island better plus make
better content or unsubscribe it's just
like damn dude
that's you man oh don't like it dude
don't like luke
dude i i tweeted that [ __ ] not so
whatever that's it
yeah go listen to the new uh love island
episode
um and watch it for the next eight weeks
it's gonna be fun
so i like i tweeted something similar
the replies
genuinely had me crying like i didn't
realize how many different things people
say
that are intentionally ass i would hate
to be
a pure music artist in this era why
people are just
they [ __ ] with you so bad it's like new
album and it's like delete it
don't care cares wow this is bad
you fell off plus yb did your album
better it's just like you know
yeah make better music make better music
before you fall off again
you get you don't get yeah that's rough
imagine posting your album release and
the
top reply is l
[Laughter]
you work on it for two years yeah yeah
in the studio
every single night yeah thinking about
it you know
sitting there at night being like maybe
yeah this song should go first before
this song maybe i should cut this one
but it doesn't matter it's [ __ ] mid
bro yb's better l l l
l shit's mid honestly shit's mad l
ah miss like damn you missed
yeah yeah people hit us with that i was
like yeah dang
first mess down for a joke song damn you
messed
it's serious out here yeah oh yeah dude
the amount of bullying on tick tock i
know i said this
every single time but it's it is wild
yeah it's mean
wild yeah and people like i've heard
people online be like yeah i think
like adults be like i think tick tock is
like a safer place
we've reverted back 20 years yeah in
some ways i like really appreciate it
yeah you know like i i think like if a
kid
were to um
like take himself out because of
bullying oh yeah i know it's dark but
it's dark what the [ __ ]
yeah whatever i'm not okay i take back
my i'm just saying i think the savagery
is so high that
a lot of the users would have to really
resist like dancing on their gray
like it's just like it's just mean out
there it really is
did i just kid cuddy it l l news article
first reply l l that's dark
yeah i mean it's really dark
she's so [ __ ] don't laugh at that dude
not laughing
it's not funny it's not funny don't
laugh stop
stop stop what are you doing what are
you doing
l death no no you know to be like no no
you know the v
all right this is you laugh you lose
right here ready
damn i guess it's f instead of l now
can we get an f
death kind of made honestly
[Laughter]
you're going to hell dude you're going
to hell oh dude that's brutal
[Laughter]
method kind of made honestly damn
damn make better tick tocks we'll
unsubscribe oh wait
oh stop stop dude
i'm not laughing that's [ __ ] up
sorry i'm sorry okay
well you know now that i've joined john
john mcafee died
speaking of death yeah john mcafee yeah
rip
no big rip though to the man john mcafee
yeah
what do we think of that i mean he he
said
if i said if i die i'm fine in here i
got good food
i'm chilling he's in jail he's like and
he also said this
enough of the whale [ __ ] is
non-consensual [ __ ]
a humpback whale weighs 70 000 pounds is
50 feet long
can dive more than a quarter mile and
can crush ships with a single swipe of
its tail
if a human manages to [ __ ] one you damn
well better believe it's consensual
i mean yeah man i mean can you argue
with that though
yeah put that on his tombstone
yeah he was he ran for prez what you
remember that i remember seeing that
dude
on cnn or like you know like just before
fast money
he's like in a plaid t-shirt being like
yeah well my platform is
bit bit bit bit bit she was the
president crazy
yeah the whole thing is pretty wild do
you think he got suicided
uh yeah because he was gonna get
extradited
yep uh from spain to
america so who killed but like why what
who killed him then
what would be the point of suiciding him
people believe that he did it but said
he didn't it's like a final [ __ ] you
yeah i see yeah
guys insane really yeah it's kind of
like it's it's i don't know
it is weird like that dude's gone now
yeah
that's it yeah yeah i mean he was like
um just one of the most prolific weirdos
ever prolific weirdo
that's a modern diss he was you prolific
weirdo i mean he just tweeted [ __ ] like
that all the time yeah he said he'd eat
his own dick if
yeah crypto if bitcoin hit uh a million
bucks or a hundred thousand bucks yeah
if they hit 100k he doesn't he's he eat
his own dick
that's like it's awful that's the first
thing i thought of
is guess we'll never get to see him i
know and here's the thing he probably
would have actually done it
yeah that's that's what we missed out on
he could have did on off and then like
made enough to buy a brand new dick
sort of been fine yeah yeah